[Music]
you look absolutely gorgeous beautiful I
understand that please tell me one thing
please tell me that you are one of those
women who you can look at yourself and
say okay I look terrific I mean I try
not to pick myself apart but I mean I
but I mean I like my bum to like a body
part I like my bum I got nice I have
enough in the rump departments happening
you got that because I don't have that
good
I've got pitch completely flat
I have this what's that called flapjack
buns
I got flapjack no I have just just
nothing it's a cheer straight drop just
flapjacks yeah you ears that's good well
I feel like I had a nice year-round
caboose and that makes me happy
I like girls that are curvier on the
bottom so the fact that I fit a portion
of that profile I'm always like trying
to do leg lifts to get my bum a little
bit bigger because I don't want to look
like Jennifer Lopez
they have implants my mom is
I don't do anesthesia right oh so you
would never get an implant or anything
yeah yeah don't do that don't do that
I've looked into it but yeah I want
something there and the doctors have
just said they're so little we can't
even it wouldn't die on the table
and all of us would die too